let's say you sit down at a stranger's
computer you start opening up files and
looking through stuff and eventually you
come to a folder that just says my work
so you open it and you click on a random
file and it's a video game that looks
like this if you had to guess what would
you say you know about this person right
now like maybe they're kind of goofy
okay you close that you scroll down a
bit and you open up a new file it's
another game do you think this person is
happy are they unhappy now another one
what do you think is comfortable for
this person what puts them at ease do
you think they're lonely what's missing
in their life
keep going open another file let's look
at all of them let's unpack this person
are they upset about something or
fighting something what do you think
makes this person angry what kinds of
friends do they have do they even enjoy
making video games at home take all of
these images hold them in your mind and
now try to imagine without ever having
met this person who they are okay let's
do it
let's find out if you're right
you